The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So a couple of things
I want to say about the
final project.
You guys should start
thinking about it.
So of course, you guys should
think about the teams first,
and submit team information.
Say who you're going
to team up with.
By when?
Team information,
Josh, by when?
Team information
has to be in--
AUDIENCE: By tomorrow.
PROFESSOR: By tomorrow.
OK, good.
You should know your teams.
Get them together, use the same
mechanism that we used
before to get the team
information before.
So we are going to add one small
thing this year I think
that would be useful.
Once you have submitted your
design documents, we are going
to get a design review
done by Masters.
So what that means is next week
we are going to schedule
a design review with
your Masters.
And you should send mail to your
Masters, hopefully in the
middle of next week, to schedule
a design review.
The design review will happen
the week after Thanksgiving.
So you'll submit your design
doc next week, and then the
week after Thanksgiving, you'll
schedule your design review.
The earlier the better, because
you can hopefully get
some really good feedback
before you go into
implementation.
So have an idea what
you're doing.
Of course you're write it up
for your design document.
And then go to your Masters
and say, here's what I'm
planning to do.
Get some good feedback, and
hopefully it will help your
life to do that.
And then beforehand, performance
only mattered for
your grade.
We did this absolute grading.
This year, we are going to
have actually an in-class
competition on the final day
of class, to figure out who
has the fastest ray tracer
in the class.
And for that we will actually
give [? you ?]
a little but of a different
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
than what I have given you.
And so you don't go too much
into really hand coding to
that teammate because
that might not work.
And so here's something
hot off the press.
So for the winning team, there's
going to be an Akamai
prize for the winning team.
And this prize includes a
celebration/demonstration at
Akamai headquarters.
You're going to go visit
there [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and perhaps show off to their
engineers the cool
ray tracer you did.
And also every team member of
the winning team is going to
get the iPod Nano.
Sorry, guys, last year
it didn't happen.
First time.
So there's a lot at stake.
So make sure your program
is going to run
as fast as you can.
OK, with that, let's
get your slides on.
So I'd like to introduce
Bradley Kuszmaul.
Bradley has been at MIT, in
and out of MIT, for a long
time doing lots of cool stuff
with high-performance--
yeah, make the screen bigger--
high-performance computing.
He has done some really
interesting data structure
work, performance optimization
work, and stuff like that.
And today he's going to talk
about an interesting data
structure that goes all the way
from theory into getting
really, really high-performance.
Thank you, Bradley.
OK, you have the mic.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So I'm going
to talk about a data structure
called fractal trees, which in
the academic world are called
streaming B-trees.
But the marketing people didn't
think very much of
that, and so a lot of these
slides are borrowed from a
company that I've started.
So rather than redo that, I'm
just going to stick to the
terminology "fractal tree." I'm
research faculty at MIT,
and I'm a founder at Tokutek.
And so that's sort
of who I am.
I'll do a little bit
more introduction.
So I have been around
at MIT a long time.
I have four MIT degrees.
And I was one of the architects
of the Connection
Machine CM-5.
And Charles was also one of the
architects of that machine.
So at the time, that was the
fastest machine in the world,
at least for some
applications.
And after getting my degrees and
being an architect, I went
and was a professor
at Yale, and then
later I was at Akamai.
So I don't know what an Akamai
prize is beyond an iPod, but
maybe it's like all your content
delivered free for a
month or something.
And I'm now research faculty
in the SuperTech Group,
working with Charles.
And I'm a founder of Tokutek,
which is commercializing some
work we did.
A couple years ago, I started
collaborating with Michael
Bender and Martin Farach-Colton
on data
structures for that are suited
for storing data on disk.
And we ended up a bit later
starting a company to
commercialize the research.
And basically, I'll tell you
sort of what the background
is, and actually go into some
technical on the data structure.
So I don't know exactly what
you've spent most of your time
on, but a lot of
high-performance work,
especially in academia, focuses
on the CPUs and using
the CPUs efficiently,
maybe getting
lots of FLOPS or something.
The Cilk work that Charles and
I did, for example, is
squarely in the category of how
do you get more FLOPS, or
more computrons out of
a particular machine.
But it turns out often I/O is
a big bottleneck, and so you
see systems that look a
little bit like this.
You have a whole bunch of
sensors somewhere, and the
sensors might be something like
a bunch of telescopes in
an astronomy system.
They're sending millions of
data items per second, and
they have to be stored.
And disk is where you have to
store large amounts of data,
because disk is orders of
magnitude per byte than other
storage systems.
And then you want to do queries
on that data, and you
want to look at the data
that's recent.
So it's not good enough just to
look at yesterday's data.
You want to know what's
going on right now.
If your sensor array is a bunch
of telescopes, and a
supernova starts happening, you
want to be able to find
out quickly what's going on, so
that you can broadcast the
message to everybody in the
world so they can all point
their telescopes at the
supernova while it's fresh.
So that's the picture.
Another example of a sensor
system is the internet, where
you have thousands or millions
of people clicking away on
Facebook, for example.
You could view that collection
of mice as, abstractly, a
bunch of sensors.
And so you see it in science.
You see it in internet.
There's lots of applications.
For example, another one would
be that you're looking for
attacks on your internet
infrastructure in a large
corporation, or something.
So trying to reduce this big
sensor system to what is the
fundamental problem, basically
we need to index the data.
So the data indexing
problem is this.
Data is arriving in one order,
and you want to ask about it
in another order.
So typically data is arriving
in the order by time.
When an observation is made,
the event is logged.
When the next observation is
made, the event is logged.
And then you want
to do a query.
Tell me everything that's
happening in that particular
area of the sky over
the past month.
So there's a big transposition
that has to be done for these
queries, abstractly, is the
data's coming in in one order,
and you want to sort
it and get the data
out in another order.
So one solution to this problem
that a lot of people
use is simply to
sort the data.
The data comes in.
Sort it.
Then you can query it in the
order that it makes sense.
This is basically a
simple-minded explanation of
what a data warehouse is.
A data warehouse is all
this data comes in--
Walmart runs one of
these in Arkansas.
All these events which are
people scanning cans of soup
on bar codes all over the
country out in Walmart stores,
all that data arrives in
Arkansas, in one location.
They sort the data overnight,
and then the next morning they
can answer questions like what's
the most popular food
in the week before a
hurricane strikes?
Because this is the kind of
request that Walmart might
care about, because they get a
forecast that a hurricane's
coming, and it turns out they
need to ship beer and
blueberry Pop-Tarts to the local
stores, which are the
things that basically you can
eat even if power has failed.
The problem with sorting
is that you
have to wait overnight.
And for Walmart, that might
actually be good enough.
But if you're the
astronomer, that
application is not so great.
So this problem is called
the indexing problem.
We have to maintain indexes.
And traditionally, the classical
solution is to use a
data structure called
a B-tree.
So do you all know
what a B-tree is?
[INAUDIBLE] data structures
to algorithms?
A B-tree is like a search tree,
except it's got some
fan-out, and I'll talk
about it in a second.
They show up in virtually all
storage systems today, and
they were invented about 40
years ago, and they show up in
databases such as MyISAM
or Oracle.
They show up in file
systems like XFS.
You can think of what Unix file
systems like EXT do as
being a variation of a B-tree.
Basically they're everywhere.
Mike might drew this picture
of a B-tree.
And I said, I don't get it.
He said, well, there's a
tree, and there's bees.
And I said, but those
are wasps.
So anyway--
So a B-tree looks like this.
It's a search tree, so that
means everything is organized.
It's got left children and right
children, and there's
actually many children.
And like any other search tree,
all the things to the
left are before all the
things to the right.
That's sort of the property of
trees that lets you do more
than just a hash table.
A hash table lets you
do get and put.
But a tree lets you do next.
And that's the key observation,
why you need
something like a tree instead
of a hash table.
A lot of database queries-- if
you go and click on Facebook
on somebody's page, there's
all these things that have
been posted on somebody's
wall.
And what they've done when they
organized that data is
that they've organized it so
that each of those items is a
row in the database, and they're
next to each other so
that you fetch the first one,
which is like the home page of
the person, and then the next
and next and next gives each
of the messages that they
want to display.
And by making those things
adjacent to each other, it
means that they don't incur
a disk I/O every time.
if it were just a hash table,
you'd be having to look all
over the place to find
those things.
So B-trees are really fast, if
you have to do insertions
sequentially.
And the reason is you have a
data structure that's too big
to fit in main memory.
If the data structure fits in
main memory, this is just the
wrong data structure, right?
If it fits in main memory, what
should you use to solve
this problem?
Any ideas?
What data structure is like a
B-tree except it doesn't have
lots of fan-out?
Does anybody know this
stuff in this class?
Do you people know data
structures at all?
Maybe I'm in the wrong place.
Because it's OK.
Just a binary tree would be the
data structure if you were
doing this in memory, right?
A binary tree would be fine.
Or maybe you would try to
minimize the number of cache
misses or something.
So for sequential inserts, if
you're inserting at the end,
basically all the stuff down the
right spine of the tree is
in main memory, and
an insertion
just inserts and inserts.
You have no disk I/Os,
and basically it
runs extremely fast.
The disk I/O is sequential.
You get basically performance
that's limited by the disk
bandwidth, which is the rate
at which the disk can write
consecutive blocks.
But B-trees are really slow if
you're doing insertions that
look random.
The database world calls
those high-entropy.
And so basically the idea is I
pick some leaf at random, and
then I have to bring it into
main memory, put the new
record in there, and then
eventually write it back out.
And because the data structure
is spread all over disk, then
each of those random blocks that
I choose, when I bring it
in, that's a random disk I/O,
which is very expensive.
So here, for this workload,
unlike the previous workload,
the performance of the system is
limited by how fast can you
move the disk head around,
rather than how fast can you
write having placed
the disk head.
And you perhaps you can only, on
a disk drive, do something
like 100 disk head movements
per second.
And if you're writing small
records that are like 100
bytes or something, you might
find yourself using a
thousandth of a percent of the
disk I/O, of the disk's
bandwidth performance.
And so people hate that.
They hate buying something and
only being able to use a
thousandth of a percent
of its capacity.
Right?
New B-trees.
Something's wrong
with that title.
So B-trees are really fast in
doing range queries, because
basically once you've are
brought a block in and you
want to do the next item,
chances are the next item's
also on the same page.
So once in while you go over a
page boundary, but mostly you
just reading stuff very fast.
Oh, I know what this is about.
When a B-tree's new and it's
been constructed sequentially,
it's also very fast.
When it gets old, what happens
is the blocks themselves get
moved around on disk.
They're not next
to each other.
And this is a problem that
people have spent a lot of
time trying to solve, is that
as B-trees get older, their
performance degrades.
This aging problem--
I saw one report that suggested
that something like
2% of all the money spent by
corporations on IT is spent
dumping and reloading their
B-trees to try to make this
problem go away.
So that's a lot of money
or pain or something.
Well, B-trees are optimal
for doing lookups.
If you just want to look
something up, there's an old
argument that says, gee,
if going to have a tree
structure, which is what you
need in order to do next
operations, then you're going to
have some path through the
B-tree which is a certain depth,
and you do it optimally
by having the fan-out
be the block size.
And everything works.
But that argument of optimality
is not actually
true for insertion workloads.
And this is where the data
structures work that I've done
with Mike and Martin sort of
gets to be an advantage.
To see that B-trees aren't
optimal for insertions--
here's a data structure that's
really good at insertions.
What is the data structure?
I'm just going to append
to the end of a file.
Right?
So it's great.
Basically, it doesn't matter
what the keys are.
I can insert data
into this data
structure at disk bandwidth.
What's the disadvantage of
this data structure?
AUDIENCE: Lookups?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Lookups.
So what is the disadvantage?
Lookups aren't so good.
What is the cost of
doing a lookup?
AUDIENCE: Order N?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Order n.
Yeah.
You have to look
at everything.
It requires a scan of
the entire table.
And we'll get into what the
cost model is in a second.
But basically, you have
to look at everything.
So it's order n.
It turns out the number of
blocks you have to read in,
which is the thing
you care about--
it's order n over b.
So we'll get into a performance
model in just a second.
So here we are.
We have two data structures--
a B-tree, which is not so
great at insertions.
It's quite good at point queries
and quite good at
ranged queries, especially
when it's young.
And we have this other data
structure, which is the append
data structure, which is
wonderful for insertions and
really bad for queries.
So can you do something that's
like the best of
all possible worlds?
You can imagine a data structure
that's the worst of
all possible, but it turns out
that there are data structures
that do well for this.
And I'll show you how one
works in a minute
So to explain how it works and
to do the analysis, we need to
have a cost model.
And we got into this just a
minute ago, with what is the
cost model for a table scan?
Is it order N?
Well, if you're only counting
the number of CPU cycles that
you're using up, it's order N,
because you have to look at
every item.
But if what you really care
about is the number of disk
I/Os, then you just count
up the number of blocks.
And so in that model, the cost
is order N over B. And that's
the model that we're going to
use to do this analysis.
So in this model, we aren't
going to care about CPU cost.
We are going to care about disk
I/O. And that's a pretty
good place to design in if
you're an engineer, because
right now the number of CPU
cycles that you get for a
dollar is going up.
It's been going up.
It's continuing to go up.
You have to write parallel
programs today to get that,
but you get a lot of cycles
in a $100 package.
But the number of disk I/Os
that you're getting is
essentially unchanged.
It's maybe improved by a factor
of two in 40 years.
So that's the one to optimize
for, is the
one that's not changing.
And use all those CPU cycles,
if you can, to do something.
So the model here is that we're
going to have a memory
and a disk.
And you could use this, and
there's some block size, B,
which we may or may not
know what it is.
And it's actually quite tricky
on real disk systems to figure
out what the right
block size is.
It's not 500 bytes, because
that's not going to be a good
block size.
It might be more like
a megabyte.
And when we move stuff back and
forth, we're going to move
a block at a time.
We're going to bring in a whole
block from disk, and
when we have to write a
block out, we write
the whole block out.
So we're just going
to count that up.
There's two parameters.
There's the block size, B, and
the memory size, M. So if the
memory is as big as the entire
disk, then the problem goes
away, and if the memory's way
too small-- like you can only
have one block--
then it's very difficult
to get anything done.
So you need to be able
to hold several
blocks worth of storage.
The memory is treated
as a cache for disk.
So once we've brought a block
in, we can keep using it for a
while until we get rid of it.
So have you guys done any
cache-oblivious data
structures?
OK.
So you've seen this model.
So the game here is to minimize
the number of clock
cycles and not worrying
about the CPU cycles.
So here's the theoretical
results.
We'll start with a B-tree.
So a B-tree which has
a block size b--
and here I'm going to assume
that the things you're storing
are unit sized.
Because you can do the analysis,
but it gets more
complicated.
So the cost of a lookup, which
is the upper right side, is
log N over log B. That's
the same as--
you may not be used to
manipulating these, but
usually people write this as
log base B of N. But that's
the same as log N over log B.
And I'm going to write it this
way, because then it's easier
to compare things.
So if B is 1,000 or
something, then
basically instead of paying--
just as an example, if N is,
say, 2 to the 40th--
let's these all to
lg's because it
basically doesn't matter.
So it's 40 over log base B,
and if B is, say, 2 to the
10th, then that means that if
you have a trillion items and
you have a fan-out of 1,000, it
takes you at most four disk
I/Os to find any particular
item.
An insertion cost is the same,
because to do an insertion, we
have to find the leaf that the
item should have been in, and
then put it there.
So the append log-- well, what's
the cost of insertion?
Well, we're appending
away, right?
And once every B items, we
actually have to do a disk
I/O. So the cost of an
insertion in the
append log isn't 0.
It's one Bth of a block
I/O per object.
And the point query cost
looks really bad.
It's N over B, which we
already discussed.
So the fractal tree has this
kind of performance.
It's log N over--
it's not B, which would
be really great.
It's something smaller.
It's maybe square root of B
for the insertion cost.
And the lookup cost is log N
over something, which I'm
going to just hide.
Let's set epsilon to 1/2 and
work out what that is.
Because epsilon 1/2 is a
good engineering point.
So the insertion cost is log N
over B to the 1/2, which is
log N over root B. And the other
one, the lookup cost--
there's all big 0's around here,
but I'm not going to
draw those again-- over 1/2--
so I'm going to maybe
ignore that--
of the log of the square root
of B. Did I do that right?
B to the 1 minus 1/2.
Put the 1/2 back in
to make you happy.
So big-O of that--
well, what's log of root B?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: I can't
quite hear you,
but I know the answer.
I can just say that's the same
as log B, when I'm doing big
0's Get rid of the halves.
So it's log N over log B. So
if you sort of choose block
sizes, if you set this parameter
to be something
where you're doing something
with the square root, you end
up having lookups that cost,
asymptotically the
same as for a B-tree.
But there are these constants
in there.
There's a factor of 4
or something that
I've glossed over.
But asymptotically,
it's the same.
And insertions have this much
better performance.
What if B was 1,000?
Then we're dividing
by 30 here.
But B isn't really 1,000.
B's more like a million
in a modern system.
So you actually get to divide by
something like 1,000 here.
And that's a huge advantage, to
basically make insertions
asymptotically be 1,000 times
faster, whatever that means.
When you actually work out the
constants, perhaps it's a
factor of 100, is what
we see in practice.
So this is basically working
out those details.
So here's an example.
Here is a data structure that
can achieve this kind of
performance.
It's a simple version of
a streaming B-tree
or a fractal tree.
And what this data
structure is--
so first of all, we're kind of
going to switch modes from
marketoid, or at least
explaining what it's good for,
to talking about what a data
structure is that actually
solves the problem.
So any questions before we
dive down that path?
OK.
So if there are any questions,
stop me.
Because I like to race through
this stuff if possible.
So the deal here is that you're
going to have log N
arrays, and each one is a
power of two in size.
And you're going to have one
for each power of 2.
So there's going to be one array
of size 1, one of size
2, one of size 4 and 8 and 16,
all the way up to a trillion,
2 to the 40th.
The second invariant of this
data structure is each array
is either completely full
or completely empty.
And the third one is that
each array is sorted.
So I'll do an example here.
If I have four elements in the
array, and these are the
numbers, there's only one way
for me to put those in that
satisfy all those
requirements.
Because there's four items,
it has to go into the
array of size four.
It has to fill it up.
I can't have any other
way of doing that.
And within that array of size
four, they have to be sorted.
So those four elements uniquely
go there, and that's
the end of the story for
where four elements go.
If there's 10 elements, you get
a little freedom, because,
well, we have to fill up the 2
array and we have to fill up
the 8 array, because there's
only one way to write in
binary 10, which is 0101.
But we get a little choice.
It turns out that the bottom
array has to be sorted and the
top array, the array
containing 5 and
10 has to be sorted.
But we could have put the five
down here and, say, swapped
the 5 and the 6, and that
would've been a perfectly
valid data structure for this
set of data as well.
So we get a little
bit of freedom.
OK?
So that's the basic
data structure.
So now what do we do?
How do you search this
data structure?
Well, the idea is just to
perform a binary search in
each of the arrays.
The advantage of this is it
works, and it's a lot faster
than a table scan.
The disadvantage is it's
actually quite a bit slower
than a B-tree, because if you do
the analysis here, which in
this class, you probably--
you've done things like master
theorem and stuff, right?
So you know what the cost of
doing the search in the
biggest array is, right?
How many disk I/Os is that
in the worst case?
AUDIENCE: Log N.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: It's log N.
It's going to be log base 2 of
N, plus or minus a little bit.
Just ignore all that stuff.
I'll just do L-O-G. So what's
the size of doing the
second-biggest array?
What's the cost of searching
the second-biggest array?
It's half as big, so it's
log of N over 2, right?
I can't write.
So this is log N. This is equal
to log of N minus 1.
What's the next array?
What's the cost of searching
the next biggest array?
Log of N minus 2--
you add that up, and
what's the sum?
We don't even need recurrences
for this.
We could have done it that
way, but what's the sum?
When we finally get down to 1,
and you search the bottom
array, you have to do one disk
I/O in the worst case.
So this is an arithmetic
sequence, right?
So what's the answer?
Big-O. I'm not even going
to ask for the--
pardon?
AUDIENCE: Log squared?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Yes, it's log
squared, which is right
there in green.
So basically, this thing
is really expensive.
Log squared N, when we were
trying to match a B-tree,
which is log N over log B. So
not only is it not log base B,
it's log base 2 or something.
But it's squaring it.
So if you think of having a
million items in your data
structure, even a relatively
small one, log base
1 million is 20.
If you square that,
that's 400.
Maybe you get to divide by 2.
It's hundreds of disk I/Os
just to do a look
up, instead of four.
So this is just sucking
at this point.
So let's put that aside and see
if we can do insertion,
since we are doing so badly
at [? logging. ?]
So to make this easier to think
about, I'm going to add
another set of temporary
arrays.
So I'm actually going to have
two arrays of each size.
And the idea is at the beginning
of each step, after
doing an insertion, all the
temporary arrays are empty.
I'm only going to have arrays
on the left side that are
going to have data in them.
So to insert 15 into this data
structure, there's only one
place to put it.
I put it in the one array, if
I'm trying to be lazy about
how much work I want to do.
And it turns out, this is
exactly what you want to do.
You have an an empty one array,
a new element comes in,
just put it in there.
Now I want to insert a 7.
There's no place in the one
array, so I'm going to put it
in the one array over
on the temp side.
And then I'm going to merge
the two one arrays
to make a two array.
So the 15 and the 7 become
7 and 15 here.
I couldn't put it there
because that
array already was full.
And then I merge those two
to make a new four array.
So this is the final
result after
inserting those two items.
Does that make sense?
It's not a hard data
structure.
So one insertion can cause
a whole bunch of merges.
Here we have sort
of an animation.
So here I've laid out the one
array across the top, and then
the temporary array just under
it, and then going down, we
have a sequence of steps for the
data structure over time.
So we have the whole arrays.
We have one and the two and the
four and the eight array
are all full, and we insert
one more item, which
causes a big carry.
So the one creates a two, the
two twos create two fours, the
two fours and the eight create
two eights, and so forth.
So here you are.
You're running.
You've built up a terabyte
of data.
Your insert one more item,
and now you have to
rewrite all of disk.
So that also sounds a
little unappealing.
But we'll build on this to make
a data structure that
actually works.
So first let's analyze what the
average cost for this data
structure is.
I've just sort of explained
why-- there are some really
bad cases where you're doing an
insertion and it's expensive.
But on average, it turns
out it's really good.
And the reason is that merging
of sorted arrays is really I/O
efficient, because the merge
is essentially operating on
that append data structure.
We're reading two append data
structures and then writing
the answer into another
append data structure.
And that does hardly any I/O.
So if you have two arrays of
size X, the cost to merge them
is you have to read the two
arrays and you have to write
the new array.
And you add it all up, and
that's order X over B I/Os.
Maybe it's 4x over
b or something.
But big-O of X over B. So
the merge is efficient.
The cost per element for the
merge is 1 over B, because
order X elements were merged
when we did that.
And we get to spread the cost.
Sure, we had to rewrite a
trillion items when we filled
up our disk, but actually, when
you divide that out over
the trillion items, it's not
that much cost per item.
And so the cost for each item of
that big operation is only
1 over B disk I/Os.
And each item only has to be
rewritten log N times.
So the total average cost for an
insertion of one element is
log N over B, which is actually
better than what I
promised here.
But this data structure's
going to be
worse somewhere else.
So this is a simplified
version.
I'll get to within--
ignoring epsilons and things,
it'll be good enough.
So does that analysis
makes sense?
It's not hard analysis, so if
it doesn't make sense, it's
not because of you.
It's got to be because I didn't
explain it, because
it's too easy to
not understand.
So if you're going to build
something like this, you can't
just say, oh, well, your
database is great except once
every couple days it hangs for
an hour while we resort
everything.
So the fix of this is that we're
going to get rid of the
worst case.
And the idea is, well, let's
just have a separate thread
that does the merging
of the arrays.
So we insert something into
a temporary array and just
return immediately.
And as long as the merge thread
gets to do at least log
N moves every time we insert
something, it can keep up.
You could actually do a very
careful dance, where I insert
something, and part of the
insertion is I have to move
something from this array and
something from this array, and
I can keep everything up to
date that way.
So it's not very hard to
de-amortize this algorithm--
that is, to turn the algorithm
from a good average-case
behavior to good worst-case
behavior.
The worst-case behavior just
becomes that it has to do log
N work for an insertion,
which isn't so bad.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does that work if
these are [INAUDIBLE] items
[INAUDIBLE]?
What if somebody wants
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Ah.
Well, OK, so the question--
let me repeat it and see if--
so you're in the middle of doing
these merges and you
have a background thread doing
that, say, and somebody comes
along and wants to do a query.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So the trick
to there is that you put a bit
on the array that says,
the new arrays is
not ready to query.
Keep using the old arrays,
which are still there.
Just don't destroy the
old ones until
the new one's ready.
So basically you have these
two megabyte-sized things.
You're trying to make a two
megabyte-sized one.
You leave the one-megabyte ones
lying around for a while
while you're incrementally
moving things down.
And then suddenly, when the big
ones done, you flip the
bits, so in order one
operations, you can say, no,
those two are no longer valid,
and this one's valid.
So queries should use this
one instead of those.
So that's basically the kind
of trick you might do.
Or you would just search the
partially constructed arrays,
if you have locks.
There's lots of ways to do it.
So that's a pretty
good question.
Yes.
That's one that we had to
think about a little.
So it sounds glib, but it's
like, how do we do this?
Any other questions?
OK.
So now we've got to do something
about the search,
because the search
is really bad.
Well, it's not as bad as the
insertion worst-case thing.
I'm going to show you how to
shave off a factor of log N,
and I don't think I'm going to
show you how to shave off the
factor of 1 over log B. so we'll
just get it down to log
N instead of log squared N.
Because if I actually want to
get it down, then I
have to give up--
remember, the performance that
I had was log of N over B. If
I actually want to get rid
of things, I have to
do something else.
There's a lower-bound
argument.
So the idea here is
we're searching--
I'm going to flip those.
We've got these arrays
of various sizes.
And I've just done a binary
search on here and then here
and then here, and I found out
the thing I'm looking for
wasn't here and it wasn't
here and it wasn't here.
That's where it would have been,
if it had been there.
It should have been there
but it wasn't.
It should have been here
And then I'm going to start
searching in this array.
And the intuition you might have
is that, gee, it's kind
of wasteful to start a whole new
search on this array when
we already knew where it
wasn't in this array.
Right?
So for example, if the data
were uniformly randomly
distributed, and the thing was,
say, 1/3 of the array
here, I might gain some
advantage by searching at the
1/3 point over here to
see if it's there.
Now, that's kind of
an intuition.
I don't know how to
make that work.
But I do know how to make
something work.
But the intuition is, having
done some search here, I
should in principal have
information about where to
limit the search so that I don't
have to search the whole
thing on the next array.
OK?
And here's basically what you
do, is every element, you get
a forward pointer to where that
element would go in the
next array.
So for example, you have
something here and something
here, which are the two things
that are less than and greater
than the thing you're
looking for.
And it says, oh, those
should have gone
here in the next array.
So if you maintain that
information, it's almost enough.
But let's gloss over
the almost part.
If those two destinations of
those two pointers are close
together, then you've
saved a lot of
search in the next array.
Does anybody see
a bug in this?
There is one.
The almost part.
You don't have to see it,
because I've been thinking
about this a lot.
The problem is, what if all of
these items are less than all
of these items, for example?
In which case, these pointers
all point down to the
beginning, and we've
got nothing.
That's a case where
this fails.
And that's allowed, right?
In particular, if we were
inserting things--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: Then we know the
element is in the biggest
array, because the element
was supposed to
go between the two.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Ah, but in
this array, we found out that
it's above the last element,
when we did our search, right?
That's one of the
possible ways--
the worst-case behavior is we've
got something where this
array is less than this array.
We're looking for that item.
So we do a binary search and
find out, it's over here.
And it doesn't help to special
case this or something,
because they could be all to the
right or they could be all
bunched up in funny ways.
There's lots of screwy ways
that this could go wrong.
But the simple version, it's
easy to come up with an
example, which is everything's
to the left.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you still save
time by, when you do the
binary search on the smallest
array-- but I guess you'd want
[INAUDIBLE]
search.
It will help reduced cost
which gives you the
next one and so on?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Yeah.
So there is a way to fix it so
that the pointers in the
smaller array do help
you reduce the
cost in the next array.
And that is to seed the smaller
array with some values
from the next array.
Like, suppose I put in every
20th item, and I stuck it in
that array with a bit on it
that says, oh, this is a
repeat, it's going to
be repeated again.
So then I could guarantee that
there's these dummies that I
throw in here, which are evenly
spaced, plus whatever
else is in there.
So put the other things in
there, and they have forward
pointers too.
And now I'm guaranteed that
the distance between two
adjacent items is guaranteed
to be a constant.
Does that make sense?
The trick is to make it so that
having found two adjacent
items that the thing
you want--
then on the next array, the
image of those two items is
separated by at most 20 items.
And so that gets you down to
only log of N instead of log
squared of n, because you're
searching constant items in
this array, and there's
only log N arrays.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't that slow down
the merging of the rays?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Not
asymptotically.
Because asymptotically,
what this means--
if I'm going to build that
array, so I'm going to merge
two arrays to make this array,
I have to do an additional
scan of this other array as
I'm constructing this one.
So the picture is I have two
arrays, and I'm trying to
merge them into this array.
And I'm trying to also insert
these dummy forward pointers
from the next array, which
is only twice as big.
So the big 0's are, if it's X,
instead of it being 1, 2, 3,
4X, it's 8X.
So it's only a constant.
So basically, I can read
all three of these.
I can read an array and the next
one and the next array,
which is twice as big, and
the next array which is
four times as big.
It all adds up to 8 times the
size of the original array.
So at least the asymptotics
aren't messed up.
Maybe the engineer in you goes,
bleh, I have to read the
data eight times.
But remember, the game here is
not to get 100% of the disk's
insertion capacity.
That's not the game, going
back to the marketing
perspective.
The competition is only
getting 0.001%
of the disk's capacity.
That's what a B-tree gets
in the worst case.
And so we don't have to get
100% to be three orders of
magnitude better, which
is where we are.
So it turns out that for this
kind of thing, we end up
getting 1% of the disk's
capacity, and everybody's
jumping around saying that's
great, because it's 1,000
times faster.
And why do we only get 1%?
Well, there's a factor of two
here and there's a log N over
there, and you divide all that,
and it's a constant
challenge, because the engineers
at Tokutek always
are having ideas for how
to make it faster.
And right now, making this data
structure faster is not
the thing that's going to
make people buy it.
Because it's already 1,000
times faster than the
competition.
What's going to make it faster
is some other thing that adds
features that make it
so it's easy to use.
So I keep having to--
no, you really need to work on
making it so that we can do
backups, or something.
It turns out, if you're selling
a database, you need
to do more than just queries
and insertions.
You need to be able
to do backups.
You need to be able to
recover from a crash.
You need to be able to cope
with the problem of some
particularly heavy query that's
going and starving all
the other queries from getting
their work done.
All those problems turn out to
be the problems that, if you
do any of them badly, people
won't buy you.
And so I suspect that there's
another factor of 10 to be
gotten over this data structure,
if you were to sit
down and try to say, how could
I make it be the fastest
possible thing.
And someday, that work will have
to be done, because the
competition will have
it and we won't.
So let's see.
I mentioned some of
these just now.
So some of the things you have
to do in order to have an
industrial strength dictionary
are you need to cope with
variable-size rows.
Now we assumed for the analysis
that the rows were
all unit size.
In fact, database rows
vary in size.
And some of them are huge.
Some of them are megabytes.
Or sometimes people do things
like they put satellite images
into databases.
So they end up having
very large rows.
You have to do deletions
as well as insertions.
And it turns out we can do
deletions just as fast as
insertions.
And the idea there is basically,
if you want to do a
delete, you just you insert
the thing with a bit on it
that says, hey, this is
really a deletion.
And then, whatever you get a
chance, when you're doing a
merge, if you find something
that has the same value, you
just annihilate it.
And the delete has to keep
going down, because there
might be more copies
of it further
down that were shadowed.
And eventually, when you finally
do the last merge,
that tombstone goes away.
You have to do transactions
and logging.
You have to do crash recovery.
And it's a big pain to get
that right, and a lot of
companies have foundered when
they tried to move from one
mode to the other.
How many of you have experienced
the phenomena that
your file system didn't come
back properly after a crash?
You see the difference
in age here.
They're all using file systems
that have transactional
logging underneath them.
When's the last time
it happened?
AUDIENCE: Tuesday.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Tuesday.
So the difference is you're
paying attention and they're
not, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
disk failure.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL:
Disk failure.
That's a different problem.
AUDIENCE: Cacheing is
not [? finalized. ?]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Yeah.
You say everybody's running
with their disk
cache turned on.
And on some file systems,
that's a bad idea.
So we're still suffering that
it's been difficult to switch
from the original Unix file
system, which is 30 years old
and wasn't designed to
recover from crash.
You have to run fsck, and
it doesn't always work.
We still have file systems
that don't
recover from crashes.
So you can see why that
could be difficult.
It turns out that one common use
case is that the data is
coming in sequentially, and this
data structure just sucks
compared to a B-tree in the case
where you're inserting
things and the data actually
is already
sorted as it's inserted.
Because this is moving things
all around and moving things
all around.
And it's like, why didn't you
just notice that it's sorted
and put it in?
You have to get rid of the log
base B to get it down to log
base B of N instead of log base
2 of N for search costs.
Because people in fact do a
lot more searches than--
if you have to choose which
to do better, you want to
generally do searches better.
And compression turns
out to be important.
I had one customer who
had a database
which was 300 gigabytes.
He has a whole bunch of servers,
and on each server,
he had a 300 gigabyte
database.
And with us, it was 70
gigabytes, because we compress.
And we just do simple
compression of, basically,
large blocks.
When we do I/Os, we do I/Os
of like a megabyte.
So when we take one of those
megabytes, we compress it.
And it's a big advantage to
compress a megabyte at a time,
instead of what--
a lot of B-trees, they have
maybe 16 kilobytes.
And gzip hardly gets a chance to
get anywhere when you only
have 16 kilobytes.
And it gets down to
12 kilobytes.
But if you have a megabyte to
work with and you compress it,
particularly if it's sorted--
so this is a megabyte of data
that's sorted, so compression
works pretty well
on sorted data.
So you get factors of 5
or 10 or something.
And so we asked him to dump the
data without the indexes,
so just the primary table with
no indexes, and then run that
through gzip.
And it was 50 gigabytes.
So the smallest he could store
the raw data was 50 gigabytes,
and we were giving him a useful
database that was 70
gigabytes that had a
bunch of indexes.
So he was like, yeah.
And you have to deal with
multithreading and lots of
clients and stuff.
So here's an example.
We worked with Mark Callahan,
who was at Google at the
time-- he's now at Facebook--
on trying to come up with some
benchmarks, because none of
the benchmarks out in the
world do a good job of
measuring this insertion
performance problem.
So iiBench is an insertion
benchmark.
And basically what it does is
it sets up a database with
three indexes, and the
indexes are random.
So it's actually harder
than real workloads.
This workload, you basically
have a row and then you create
a random key to point
into that from
three different places.
Real databases, it turns out,
probably have more of a
Zipfian distribution.
Have you talked at all about
Zipfian distributions of data?
So this is sort of an
interesting thing.
If you're dealing with
real-world caches, you should
know that data ain't uniformly
randomly distributed.
That's a poor model.
So in particular, suppose I have
memory and disk, and this
is 10% of the disk.
Very simple situation.
Very common ratio.
You'll see, this
is how Facebook
sets up their databases.
They'll have a 300-gigabyte
database and 30 gigs of RAM.
If the queries that you wanted
to do were random, it wouldn't
matter what data structure
you were using.
Let's suppose that God tells
you where it is on disk, so
you don't have to find it.
You just have to move the
disk head and move it.
If they're random, then
basically, no matter what
you've done, 90% of the queries
you have to do are
going to do a random disk I/O.
10% are going to already be
there, because you got lucky.
So that is not reflecting
what's going on on any
workload that I know.
What they'll see is more like
99% of the queries hit here,
and 1% go out here, or maybe 95%
here and 5% go out there.
And it turns out that, that for
a lot of things, there is
a model of what's going on
called a Zipfian distribution.
This would a random uniform
distribution.
It's like every item has equal
probability of being chosen
for a query.
It turns out that for things
like what's the popularity of
web pages, or if you have a
library, what's the frequency
at which words appear
in the library--
so words like "the" appear
frequently, and words like
"polymorphic" are
less frequent.
So Zipf came up with this model,
and there's a simple
version of the model, which
says that the most popular
word has probability
proportional to 1.
It's not going to be 1.
It's going to be proportional
to 1.
The second most popular word
is going to have 1/2.
The third most popular
word is 1/3.
And the fourth most popular word
is 1/4 the probability of
the first word, and so forth.
So if you plot this
distribution, it kind of looks
like this, right?
It's like 1 over x.
And what would you tell me if
I told you that I had an
infinite universe of objects
that had a probability
distribution like this.
Does that seem plausible?
Why?
You're saying no.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
try adding them all together.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: If
you add them all
together, it doesn't converge.
So it's a heavy-tailed
distribution.
So it turns out that if you sum
up these up to 1, the sum
from 1 to n of 1 over i, it's
the nth harmonic number.
And that grows over time.
It's basically like the integral
under this curve,
from 1 to n.
It's close to that.
And what is the integral
of that?
It's like something you learned
seven years ago, and
now you've forgotten, right?
You learned it when you
were sophomores in
high school, or something.
So it's approximately
log of n.
It's actually like log of n
plus 0.57, is a very good
approximation for the
nth harmonic number.
When you're doing this kind of
analysis, boy, it depresses
people, because you say, oh,
that's H of n, and if you have
a million items in your
database, then the sum of all
those things is H of
1 million, and
what's H of 1 million?
Well, the log base 2 of 1
million, I know that, because
I'm a computer scientist.
So it's going to be like 20,
and because we're doing log
base e in that formula, maybe
it's 15 or something.
So if you have 1 million items,
then the most popular
item is going to-- you have
to divide by H of n here.
So the most popular
item is going to
appear 1/15 of the time.
And the next most popular item
is going to appear--
emergency backup chalk.
Somebody's been burning both
ends of this chalk.
1/30 of the time, and 1/45 of
the time, and those add up.
When you go up to 1
over 1 million--
another zero in there--
times 15, that finite series
will add up to 1,
approximately.
Except to the extent that
I've approximated.
So this is what's going on.
So the most popular
Facebook page--
they might have 1 billion
pages, so how
does that change things?
Well, that means the most
popular one has a probability
1 in 20, and the second
most is 1 in 40.
And this explains why
cache works for
this kind of workload.
Nobody really knows why Facebook
pages and words in
libraries and everything else
have this distribution, which
is named after a
guy named Zipf.
But they do.
Everything has this property.
And so you can sort of predict
what's happening.
So iiBench should
have a Zipfian
distribution and it doesn't.
So this is painting
a worse picture.
Or a better picture.
It's making us look better than
we really are, because
the real world is going to have
more hits on the stuff
that's in memory for a B-tree
than this model, where
basically you're completely
hosed all the time because
it's random.
So this is an example in the
category of how to lie with
statistics.
And it's a pretty sophisticated
lie.
If you're going to lie,
be sophisticated.
So these measurements were
taken in the top graph.
Up is good.
It's how many rows per second
we could insert.
And this axis is how many rows
have been inserted so far.
And the green one is a B-tree.
According to Mark Callahan,
who's essentially a
disinterested observer, it's the
best implementation of a
B-tree ever.
And you can sort of see what
happens, is that as you insert
stuff, the system falls out
of main memory, and the
performance was really good
at the beginning--
40,000 per second-- and then
boom, you're down to 200 down
here at the end, by
the time you've
inserted a billion rows.
Whereas, for the fractal
tree, you can
sort of see this noise.
That's because some insertions
are a little cheaper than
other insertions.
Every other insertion's
completely free, right?
You had a free spot.
You just put it in.
One out of four insertions, the
ones that weren't free,
half of them only had to do a
little operation in memory.
So you see this high frequency
noise, because some things are
cheaper than others.
And that's like a factor
of 30 or something.
It turns out it even works
on SSD, solid state disk.
You might think--
all this time I've been talking
about disk drives.
Solid state disk has a
complicated cache hierarchy
inside it, and we were
surprised to see that
basically we're faster on this
workload on a rotating disk
than a B-tree is on an SSD,
which is orders of magnitude
faster in principle, but turns
out that for various
reasons it's not.
One question I get often is, the
world is moving away from
rotating disk to solid
state disk.
A lot of applications--
how many of you have solid state
disks in your laptops?
That's a really good application
for a solid state
disk, because it's
not sensitive to
being knocked around.
So it's worth it to have a solid
state disk even if it
were more expensive,
which it is.
It turns out it's not
that much more
expensive for a laptop.
It's a couple of hundred dollars
more or something.
But the advantage of it is
that if you go up in an
airplane and you're sitting
and trying to type in the
middle of a thunderstorm,
flying across--
it doesn't care.
Disk drives, if you do that--
disk drives do not like flying
at high altitude, because they
work by having a cushion of air
that the head is flying
on, and in airplanes, which
pressurize the cabin to the
same altitude as 8,000 feet,
that's half an atmosphere.
So there's only half as much
air keeping it off.
So if you travel a lot, that's
when your disk drive will
fail, is when you're flying.
OK.
So it looks like, however that
rotating disk is getting
cheaper faster then solid
state disk is.
So rotating disk is an order of
magnitude cheaper per byte
than solid state disk today.
Maybe two orders of
magnitude cheaper.
It's hard to measure fairly.
But rotating disk, according
to Seagate--
they're saying, by the end of
the decade, we'll have 70
terabyte drives that are
the same form factor.
And so you figure out what the
Moore's Law is for that, and
it's better than for
lithography.
Lithography is not going
to be that much more
dense in that timeframe.
So at least for the next 5 or
10 years, it looks like disk
drives are going to maintain
their cost advantage over
solid state storage,
and maybe even
spread that cost advantage.
So for any particular
application, for storing your
music, SSD will be cheap enough,
but for those people
that have really big data
sets, like these new
telescopes they're
putting up--
these new telescopes
are crazy.
These people are putting
up these telescopes.
They're putting up 1,500
telescopes across the
Australian Outback.
And each of those telescopes in
the first 15 minutes live
is going to produce more data
than has come down from the
Hubble, total.
And there's just no
way for them to--
I don't know what they're
going to do.
But it's a huge amount of data,
and they're going to
have to use disks to store
whatever it is that
they want to keep.
And they don't like throwing
away data, because it's so
expensive to make.
So if I were a disk maker, I'd
make sure that my salesmen had
an office somewhere out there.
So the conclusion is you're not
going to be able to, at
least for those applications,
just have an
index in main memory.
You're going to have to have
a data structure that
works well on disk.
The speed trends--
well, seek time is not
going to change.
It hasn't changed.
It's not going to change.
The bandwidth of a disk drive
grows with the square root of
its capacity.
So if you quadruple the storage
on the disk because
you've made the bits twice as
dense in each dimension, then
one spin of the disk sees twice
as many disks, not four
times as many disks.
So that projects out to
something like disks that are
500 megabytes per second.
So how long is it going to take
to back up a 67 terabyte
disk drive?
So there remain systems
problems.
And I was explaining to my son
that there's all these
problems in systems.
Data structures aren't suited,
and all these systems suck.
He said, well, isn't
that horrible if
you're computer scientist?
I said, no, because
we make our living
off of these problems.
So here are some problems.
There's plenty of living
to be made yet.
Power consumption is also a big
issue for these things.
If you fill up a room a Google
data center, a room which is
probably bigger than this
room, full of machines.
The Facebook data center is
probably a room about this
size, full of machines.
And power and cooling is
something like half the cost
of the machines.
The machines for something like
Facebook, the hardware
might cost them $10 million or
$20 million a year, and the
heating and cooling is another
$10 million or $20 million a
year, which is why they go off
and they build these data
centers in places like North
Carolina, where I guess
they're willing to give them
power for free or something.
So making good use of disk
bandwidth offers huge power
savings, because basically you
can use disks which are
cheaper than solid
state for power.
And you want to use that well.
CPU trends.
Well, you've probably talked
about this, right?
CPUs are going to get
a lot more cores.
I actually have a 48-core
machine that cost $10,000 that
I bought about a month ago.
And our customers mostly
use machines that
are like $5,000 machines.
So when I provisioned this
machine, I said, well, I
should spend and buy a machine
that's twice as good as what
they're buying, because I'm
developing software that
they're going to
use next year.
So I bought a $10,000 machine,
which is 48 cores.
And we're having all
sorts of making a
living with that machine.
The memory bandwidth and the I/O
bus bandwidth will grow.
And so I think it's going to get
more and more exciting to
try to use all these cores.
Fractal trees have a lot of
opportunity to use those cores
to improve and reduce the
number of disk I/Os.
So the conclusion is, basically,
these data
structures dominate B-trees
asymptotically.
And then B-trees have 40 years
of engineering advantage, but
that will evaporate
eventually.
These data structures ride
better technology curves than
B-trees do, and so I find it
hard to believe that in 10
years that anybody would
design a system using a
B-tree, because how do you
overcome those advantages.
So basically all storage systems
are going to use data
structures that are like this,
or something else.
There's a whole bunch of other
kinds of indexes that we
haven't attacked, things like
indexing multi-dimensional
data or indexing data where you
have very large keys, very
large rows.
Imagine that you're trying to
index DNA sequences, which are
much bigger than a disk block.
So there's a whole bunch of
interesting opportunities.
And that's what I'm
working on.
So any questions or comments?
Arguments?
Fistfights?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Where's the mic?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Where
is the mic?
AUDIENCE: That's OK.
I can [INAUDIBLE].
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL:
It's on my coat.
PROFESSOR: So actually, this is
a very interesting point,
because if you think where the
world is leading, I think that
big data is something that's
very, very interesting,
because all these people are
gathering huge amounts of
data, and they're storing
huge amounts of data.
And what do with data, accessing
them, is going to be
one big problem.
I mean, if you look at what
people like Google are doing,
they're just collecting
all those.
Nobody's throwing
anything out.
And I believe if you to kind of
look at them, analyze them,
do cool things with the
data, it's going to
be very, very important.
So I think that would
be very interesting,
high-performance end.
It's not just doing
number crunching.
Until now, when people look at
high-performance, it's about CPU.
It's about how many FLOPS
per second can you do?
TeraFLOPS, petaFLOP machines
and stuff like that.
But I think one thing
that's really
interesting is it's not petaFLOPS.
How many terabytes of
data can you process
through to find something.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So I was at
a talk by Facebook, and they
serve 37 gigabytes per data
per second out of their
database tier.
And that's a lot of serving.
Out of one little piece of
whatever they're doing.
Those guys have three
or five petabytes.
And in the petabyte club,
they're small potatoes.
There's people who have hundreds
of petabytes, people
with three-letter acronyms.
PROFESSOR: I mean, some of those
three-letter acronym
places, the amount of data they
are getting and they are
processing is just gigantic.
And I think to a point that even
some of the interesting
things about--
if they keep growing their data
centers at the rate they
keep growing in the next couple
of decades, they will
need the entire power of the
United States to power their
data centers, because they
are at that kind of
thing at this point.
Even in these big national labs,
the reason they can't
expand is not that they don't
have money to buy the
machines, but they don't have
money to pay for the
electricity, and also they don't
have electricity-- that
much electricity--
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
them to basically feed it.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: I've run into
people for whom the power
issue was a big deal.
I look at it and say, eh, you
bought a $5,000 machine.
You spend $5,000 in power over
the lifetime of the machine.
It doesn't seem like it's
that big a deal.
But they've filled up their data
center, and the cost of
adding one more machine has a
huge incremental cost, because
they can't fit one more in.
So that means they have to
build another building.
And so almost everybody's facing
that problem who's in
this business.
And then they try to build a
building somewhere where
there's natural cooled--
Google's written these papers
about, oh, it turns out if you
don't air condition your
computers, most
of them work anyway.
So, well, air conditioning is a
quarter of the cost over the
lifetime of the computer.
So if you can make more than 3/4
of them give you service,
you come out ahead.
GUEST SPEAKER: On that note,
MIT is part of a consortium
that includes Harvard,
Northeastern, Boston
University, and University of
Massachusetts Amherst, to
relocate all of our
high-performance computing
into a new green data center
in Holyoke, Massachusetts.
So the idea is that rather than
us locating things here
on campus, where the energy
costs are high and we get a
lot of our energy from fuels
that have a big carbon
footprint, locating
it in Holyoke--
they have a lot of hydro power
and nuclear power there.
And they're able to build a
building that is extremely
energy-efficient.
And it turns out that a bunch
of years ago when they were
digging up the Route 90, the
Mass Pike, they laid a lot of
dark fiber down the length.
And so what they're going to
do is light up that fiber,
which comes right back here
to the Boston area.
And so for most people who
are using these very
high-performance things, it
doesn't really matter where
it's located anymore, at
the level of that.
So instead of just locating some
piece of equipment here,
we just will locate it out
there, and the price will drop
dramatically.
And it'll be a much greener
way for us to be doing our
high-end computing.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Isn't someone talking
about water-cooled
offshore floating
data centers?
GUEST SPEAKER: Sure.
Sure.
So the question is, are people
talking about water-coooled
offshore floating data centers.
Yeah.
I mean, locating things in some
area where you can cool
things easily makes
a lot of sense.
Usually, they tend to want those
near rivers rather than
in the middle of the ocean,
just because you get the
hydropower.
But even in the ocean, you can
use currents to do very much
the same kind of thing.
So for some of these things,
people are looking very
seriously at a whole bunch of
different strategies for
containing large-scale
equipment.
PROFESSOR: So one that's very
counterintuitive is people are
trying to build data centers in
the middle of deserts, when
it's very hot.
I mean, why do you think people
want to build a data
center in the middle
of the desert?
AUDIENCE: Solar power?
PROFESSOR: Solar power
is one thing.
No, it's not solar power.
AUDIENCE: It gets really
cold at night.
PROFESSOR: No, it's not
really cold at night.
That's not it.
GUEST SPEAKER: Cheap property.
PROFESSOR: No, the biggest thing
about cooling is either
you can do air conditioning,
where you're using power to
pull heat out, or you can
use just water to cool.
And what happens is most of
other places is the humidity
is too high.
And when you go to the desert,
humidity is low enough that
you can just pump water through
the thing and get the
water evaporation going
by, and then use
that to cool the system.
So sometimes they're looking
at data centers in places
where it could be 120 degrees,
but very low humidity.
And they think that is
a lot more efficient
to cool than that.
So there are a lot of these
interesting nonintuitive
things people are looking at.
So what [UNINTELLIGIBLE] they
say is that humidity's the
killer, not the temperature.
AUDIENCE: What if you're
located on the South--
if you're located on the South
Pole, then that's both cold
and really low humidity.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
I mean it'll be interesting to
see how these things develop.
It's a very so-called hot topic
these days, is energy
for computing.
And the energy for computing
of course matters also not
only at the large scale but
also at the small scale,
because you want your
favorite handheld to
use very little battery.
So your batteries last longer.
So the issue of energy, using
that as a measure--
we've mostly been looking at
how fast we can make things
run in this class, but many of
the lessons you can use to
say, well, how can I
make this run as
energy-efficient as possible?
And what you'll learn is that
many of the lessons we've had
in the class during the term
we focused, as I say, on
performance.
But there are many resources
in any given situation that
you might want to optimize.
And so understanding something
about how do I minimize
energy, how do I minimize disk
I/Os, how do I minimize clock
cycles, how do I minimize
off-chip accesses--
which tend to be much
more energy
intensive than on-chip--
all those different kinds of
measures end up being part of
the mix of what you have to do
when you're really engineering
these systems.
PROFESSOR: So I think another
interesting thing is, because
we are in this time where some
stuff grows at exponential
rates and stuff like that, some
of those ratios that made
sense at some point just
suddenly start making really
bad things.
Like, for example, in this, at
some point the seek times were
normal enough that
you didn't care.
And at some point, because the
rest of the things took off so
fast, suddenly it becomes
this really, really big
bottlenecks.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: B-trees
were a really good data
structure in 1972.
Because, well, the seek
time and the transfer
time and the CPU--
the CPUs actually couldn't
read in the data in one
rotation, so people didn't even
read consecutive blocks,
because the CPU just couldn't
handle data
coming in that fast.
You would stagger blocks around
the disk, so that when
you did sequential reads, you'd
get this one and then
this one and this one.
There was this whole thing about
tuning your file system.
It's like--
AUDIENCE: By the way, back
when disks were--
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Yeah.
Washing machine.
AUDIENCE: Washing
machine size.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: For
20 megabytes.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, that's
the big disk.
So hopefully you guys
got a feel for--
we have been looking at this
performance on a small
multi-core and stuff like that,
how it can scale in
different directions and
the kind of impact
performance can have.
And in fact, if anybody has read
books on why Google is
successful, one of the biggest
things for their success is
they managed to do a huge amount
of work very cheaply,
because the amount of work they
do, if anybody did in the
traditional way, they can't
afford that model, to give it
for free or give it supplied
for advertising.
Because they can get it done
because it's about
optimization.
Performance, Performance
basically relates to cost.
And if the cost is low enough,
then they don't have to keep
charging a huge amount of
money for each search.
GUEST SPEAKER: So let's
thank Dr. Kuszmaul for
an excellent talk.
And can you hang out for just
a little bit, if people want
to come down?
OK.
Thanks.